a tourist
is uh backpacking through the highlands
of scotland
and he stops at a pub to get a drink and
the only people in there is a bartender
and an old man nursing a beer and he
orders a pint and they sit in silence
for a while and suddenly the old man
turns to him and goes you see this bar
i built this bar with my bare hands
found the finest wood in the county
gave it more love and care than my own
child but do they call me mcgregor the
bar builder
no points out the window you see that
stone wall out there
i built that stone wall with my bare
hands found every stone placed them just
so through the rain and the cold but do
they call me mcgregor the stonewall
builder
no points out the other window you see
that pier on the lake out there
i built that pier with my bare hands
drove the pilings against the tide of
the sand
planked by plank but did they call me
mcgregor the pier builder
no but you [ __ ] one goat
storytelling
is joke-telling it's knowing your
punchline
your ending knowing that everything
you're saying from the first sentence to
the last is leading
to a singular goal and ideally
confirming
some truth that deepens our
understandings of who we are
as human beings we all love stories
we're born for them stories affirm who
we are
we all want affirmations that our lives
have meaning and nothing does a greater
affirmation
than when we connect through stories it
can cross the barriers of time
past present and future and allow us to
experience the similarities between
ourselves
and through others real and imagined the
children's television host
mr rogers always carried in his wallet
a quote from a social worker that said
frankly there isn't anyone you couldn't
learn to love
once you've heard their story and the
way i like to interpret that
is probably the most greatest
story commandment which is
make me care please emotionally
intellectually aesthetically just make
me care
we all know what it's like to not care
you've gone through hundreds of tv
channels just switching after
channel after channel and then suddenly
you actually stop on one
it's already halfway over but
something's caught you
and you're drawn in and you care that's
not by chance that's by
design andrew stanton is one of the most
famous storytellers in hollywood
his movies toy story finding nemo and
wally to name but a few
have become blockbusters and have
probably revolutionized the way we view
and perceive animated character films
their incredible narrative
is not based on luck nor was it a
momentary inspiration
andrew stanton while writing these
stories knew exactly where to focus on
and how to make them successful
in his own words he actually knew how to
care
like andrew stanton i did not decide to
start this video with a recount of his
story by chance
i wanted to actually find a concrete way
to introduce you to the power of
storytelling
for i hold the conviction that
storytelling is a skill
every single one of us ought to
understand and eventually
to cultivate
i will try to illuminate the essence of
a great story by narrating a modified
excerpt
from the short story shahir azad by the
great novelist haruki murakami
when i was young i loved listening to my
grandfather tell me stories
i didn't know whether his stories were
true invented
or partly true and partly invented i had
no way of knowing
reality and supposition observation and
pure fancy
seemed jumbled together in his
narratives i therefore enjoyed them as a
child might without
even asking too many questionings what
possible difference could it make to me
after all if they were
lies or truth or a complicated patchwork
of the two
whatever the case my grandfather had a
gift for storytelling that touched me in
my heart no matter what sort of story it
was
he managed to make it special his voice
his timing and his spacing
were all flawless enthralled i was able
to forget the reality that surrounded me
if only for a moment like a blackboard
wiped with a damp cloth
my worries were erased as were
unpleasant memories
at this point in my life this kind of
forgetting
was what i desired more than anything
else
the essence of a great story is its
ability not only to make you care as
andrew stanton stated
but also to make you forget forget your
worries
your problems even your pain the story
helps you enter a new
magical world that is extremely
appealing
the person who helps you achieve such a
thing automatically becomes
extremely appealing too so why is this
actually happening
what kind of process occurs in our
brains that can help us
experience all of the feelings evoked by
great story
let's say you are in a meeting room and
you have to attend a powerpoint
presentation
by one of your colleagues during this
process two parts of your brain the
broca's area and the vernicas area are
activated
these are the language processing areas
which help us decode
words and determine meaning other than
that they don't do anything
therefore when this process takes place
alone it's almost impossible for our
brains to feel engaged
with the speaker and we consequently
lose interest when we are being told the
story however
things change dramatically not only are
the language processing parts in our
brain activated
but so is any other area of our brain
that we would use to experience the
events of the story
in essence you're not just listening to
a story you're making yourself
part of it yuri hasson associate
professor of psychology at princeton
university
in one of his papers states when we
narrate stories that have had a huge
impact on our lives
we can pass the feeling we have
experienced to other people too
during a research study when the
narrator spoke english
the volunteers understood her story and
their brain synchronized
when she had activity in her insulin
which is an emotional brain region
the listeners did too when her frontal
cortex
lit up so did theirs by simply telling a
story the woman could plant ideas
thoughts and emotions into the listeners
brains
so anything you have experienced you can
help others experience the same thing
or at least activate the same brain
areas in them
that were activated during your
experience
storytelling is an essential part of
communication it is the most effective
way to learn
digest information become energized be
influenced and get carried away
although it seems quite challenging to
master the art of storytelling
when you manage to understand the main
principles of a great story
you are in a position to deconstruct
them and build a system off of them
my storytelling system is called see you
and it is inspired by andrew stanton's
ted talk
as well as countless interesting stories
i have heard and read the main pillars
of the system are as follows
stick to a central theme evoke wonder
embrace
change use personal experience
as andrew stanton states all well-drawn
characters within a story have a spine
this is their inner motor a dominant
unconscious goal that they are striving
towards
a niche that they cannot scratch michael
corleone for instance in the godfather
was driven by a constant underlying
theme which was
to please his father it consumed his
entire life
and it was visible throughout the movie
when you're telling a story
whether you want to draw on details from
your personal experiences or from
somewhere else
try to be congruent with your theme is
your story about
existential angst is your story about
the struggle of being human
is it about the depth of your emotional
or intellectual world
whatever your theme and its emotional
underpinning
make sure that it prevails throughout
the story this is what keeps people
engaged
and helps them resonate with your
emotional world
and that's what i think the magic
ingredient is the secret sauce
is can you invoke wonder wonder is
honest it's completely innocent it can't
be
artificially evoked for me there's no
greater ability than the gift of another
human being
giving you that feeling to hold them
still just for a brief moment in their
day
and have them surrender to wonder when
it's tapped the affirmation
of being alive reaches you almost to a
cellular level
and when an artist does that to another
artist it's like you're compelled to
pass it on
it's like a dormant command that's
suddenly activated in you like a call to
devil's tower do unto others what's been
done to you
the best stories infuse wonder let me
repeat his words so you can realize the
profanity of what he just said
managing to hold your audience still for
just a brief moment in their day
and have them surrender to wander is a
skill that when performed correctly
can reach you to an almost cellular
level a great example of a person who
manages to evoke wander in his speeches
is dr jordan peterson
here is a small clip that signifies that
beauty is so valuable and we're so
afraid of it
and i think we're afraid of it because
it does it's a pathway it's not the only
pathway to the divine i mean there's a
lot there's pathways to the divine
love is one of them i suppose but beauty
especially for people who have
an affinity for beauty it's it's like
music it's one of those things that you
can't argue against right
you can't even understand it just hits
you and
and it does it shows you well it shows
you the ideal that's one way of thinking
about it but
it also shows you i think it's like a
vision of the potential future
it's something like that as well that if
we just got our act together and
beautified things that that's the place
that we can inhabit and that would
ennoble us
and that's why this jerusalem the
heavenly city is paved with gemstones
you know they're crystalline they emit
light and
yeah it's the proper dwelling place for
an enlightened consciousness
beauty is the proper dwelling place for
an enlightened consciousness
and we we ignore it at our spiritual and
economic peril it's like it's obvious
that beauty there's almost nothing more
valuable than beauty
he has this incredible ability to talk
about big ideas and
attempt to answer life-defining
questions just by choosing topics that
can speak to our unconscious mind and
help us feel
immediately engaged wonder is strongly
associated with themes
that are not commonly experienced in our
everyday lives
or with situations that flirt with the
idea of the extraordinary and are
difficult to achieve
whenever you want to spice up your story
with wonder try to think of events where
the protagonist exceeded the
expectations of his or her surroundings
and accomplish something beautiful and
extraordinary
so we're all learning all the time and
that's why change is fundamental in
story
if things go static stories die because
life is never static
in 1998 i had finished writing a toy
story in a bug's life
and i was completely hooked on
screenwriting so i wanted to become much
better at it and learn anything i could
so i researched everything i possibly
could
and i finally came across this fantastic
quote by a british playwright william
archer
drama is anticipation mingled with
uncertainty
it's an incredibly insightful definition
when you're telling a story have you
constructed
anticipation in the short term have you
made me want to know what will happen
next but more importantly have you made
me want to know
how it will all conclude in the long
term
have you constructed honest conflicts
with truth that creates
doubt in what the outcome might be an
example would be in finding nemo
in the in the short tension you were
always worried would dory's short-term
memory make
forget whatever she was being told by
marlon but under that was this global
tension of will we ever
find nemo in this huge vast ocean
change and anticipation is what makes us
crave for more
andre stanton knows that pretty well and
at some point he makes this excellent
comment
make the audience work for their meal
give them just enough so that they want
to find out more
humans are born problem solvers we are
compelled to deduce and to deduct
because
this is what real life actually looks
like it is this well-organized absence
of information that will draw us in
give your audience a two plus two in a
story never give them a four
the elements you provide and the order
you place them in
is crucial to whether you will succeed
or fail in engaging with your audience
use what you know draw from it doesn't
always mean plot or fact
it means capturing a truth from your
experiencing
expressing values you personally feel
deep down to your core personal stories
help us to speak from our hearts
once we do so the listener immediately
identifies value in our story and can
easily relate to it
as discussed earlier people want you to
make them care
or sometimes even forget that is why
personal experiences are important
they are the most effective way to make
yourself relatable
and help others become lost in your
narrative the best storytellers look for
their own memories and life experiences
for ways to illustrate their message
what events in your life make you
believe in the idea that you're sharing
the whole world is built on stories
religions political parties
companies and various social groups are
using storytelling to promote their
ideas
as you all know a harare wrote in
sapiens humans thinking stories
and we try to make sense of the world by
telling stories
i don't know which stories are the best
but there is one thing i know for sure
if you're not capable of writing your
own story other people will write it
for you hey guys hope you enjoyed
today's video
if you did make sure to like subscribe
turn on notifications
and comment below something cool please
so that more people can discover it
uh if you want to watch more videos from
my channel check out this one
and this one take care see you soon
either now